the Hyperion cantos is a series of four
science fiction novels written by Dan
Simmons the story takes place hundreds
of years in our future at a time where
humankind has formed the hegemony
spreading out to many planets mankind
also now had the technology to instantly
travel from any world connected in the
far casting web the books mainly centre
however on the far off planet of
Hyperion where the merciless strike
resides the creature known as the strike
in the Hyperion cantos is one of the
most intriguing characters to come out
of modern science fiction the creature
which was named for the carnivorous
passerine birds of Old Earth terrorizes
the world of Hyperion the Shrike is a
being of mysterious origin an incredible
power the Shrike appeared in the books
as four armed and vaguely humanoid its
entire body was comprised of some
strange metal similar to steel with
countless barbs and spikes covering it
throughout the series the shrikes goals
and motivations are ambiguous it seems
to act with no rhyme or reason the
Shrike first appeared on Hyperion with
the arrival of the time tombs six
strange structures in a distant Valley
on the world the time tombs were
constructed at some point in the distant
future and were sent hurtling backwards
through time it is assumed early on that
the Shrike itself was also created at
some point in the distant future but for
an unknown purpose on the planet
Hyperion the being called the Shrike
impales its victims upon the tree of
pain a giant structure made of a similar
material to the creature itself impaled
upon the spikes of the shrikes tree its
victims would be condemned to suffer
eternally fully conscious and aware of
their own agony the strikes victims
could potentially numb
the millions the Shrike had the power to
move through the void which binds in
order to travel through time and space
it could travel anywhere but for the
vast majority of its existence it chose
to reside solely on the planet Hyperion
in a territory that it had chosen the
Shrike could move so fast that it often
appeared to be in two places at once and
its many thorns and spikes could easily
butcher any opponent it faced normal
weapons had no effect on the striking
and the creature often intentionally
chose to mutilate its opponents and
exceedingly horrifying and painful ways
perhaps due to the ambiguity of its
origins and due to the godlike power of
the Shrike the Church of the final
atonement was formed after the Shrike
first appeared on Hyperion the Shrike
church revered the entity naming it the
Lord of pain many within the Galactic
hegemony believed the church to be a
cult the Church believes that one day
the Shrike will unleash its rage unto
the inhabited worlds of the galaxy and
punished the living for the sins of
mankind it is suggested in the later
books that the strike may have been the
final result of something that evolved
alongside the technic or the entity
created through the amalgamation of all
sentient artificial intelligence it was
called the reaper program the reaper
program was originally designed to
maintain order amongst the first AIS and
as the eons passed and the AI is formed
into the Technic or the reaper program
continuously grew and evolved as well
eventually creating the Shrike the
Shrike acted as the Avatar to the old
intelligence an AI god created by the
techno core in the distant future it had
known true motive of its own it is
somewhat in flight that the strike had
been sent back in time to seek out the
human counterpart to the ultimate
intelligence which was the collected
conscience of humanity the ultimate
human intelligence would reside
somewhere in the void which binds it is
possible that the strikes tree of
painting was intended to draw out the
human intelligence so that the strike
could eliminate it before it was ever a
threat to its AI equivalent the strike
is of key importance in the Hyperion
cantos it appears in each of the four
novels and is a part of every major
character arc in the series